Derek white out the halters lights and
recovers and block the shot by Aldridge
that's a great defensive play by
Whiteside to the three-point shooter
Ellington always in rhythm that was just
the second assist of the season for
Whiteside he just picked up his second
block of the first group Winslow the
trailer climbs the ladder enough space
for that catch and shoot the 11 straight
points for the Whiteside with his third
block of the quarter
and here comes Miami another block that
he keeps in play which triggers the heat
in transition oh what a great pass all
five of his Spurs out of the game you
don't hardly ever see that run in the
floor big hassan getting the block now
the early post up job by Whiteside he's
got four points on a couple of assists
four rebounds and taken blocks he just
sent it back on hurdle Jakub hurdle just
coming into the game I mean ahead 36 to
30 Whiteside 14 points 9 rebounds five
blocks all on the first fool Belinelli
Whiteside got number six is something
else it done is the ultimate rim
protector good read not over committing
so Belinelli could dump it off side who
continues to make himself available but
those nice hands to catch in finish
another block for Whiteside sent it back
at Myrtle and look at the sign
McGruder's against her roses white side
again eight blocks of a hand for a sound
white side that's a new franchise record
eight blocks in any half go get them
646 left is Mills by Whiteside is late
to the game now the sooner does he
reactor